we've gone over the general idea behind
mitosis and meiosis it's a good idea in
this video to go a little bit more in
detail i've already done a video on
mitosis and in this one we'll go into
the details of meiosis and this is a
review mitosis you start with a diploid
cell
you start with a diploid cell and you
end up with two diploid cells it's
essentially it just duplicates itself
and formally mitosis is really the
process of the duplication of the
nucleus but it normally ends up with two
entire cells of cytokinesis takes place
so this is mitosis and we have a video
on it where we go into the phases of it
prophase metaphase anaphase and
telophase
mitosis
meiosis which and this occur mitosis
occurs in pretty much all of our our our
somatic cells you know as our
our our skin cells replicate and our
hair cells and our um you know
all the tissue in our body is it
duplicates itself it goes through
mitosis meiosis occurs in the germ cells
and it's used to essentially produce
gametes to facilitate sexual
reproduction so
if i start off with a diploid cell and
that's my diploid cell right there this
would be a germ cell it's not just any
cell in the body
it's a germ cell
it could undergo mitosis to produce more
germ cells but we'll talk about how it
produces the gametes it actually goes
under two rounds the first round is and
they're combined called meiosis but the
first round you could call it meiosis
one
so i'll call that m1
i'm not talking about the money supply
here and in the first round of meiosis
this diploid cell essentially splits
into two haploid cells
so if you start off with 43 chromosomes
you formally have
23 chromosomes in each one
or you can almost view it if you have 23
pairs here each have two chromosomes you
those pairs get split into this stage
and then in meiosis 2
and meiosis 2
these things get split and a in a
mechanism very similar to my mitosis
so we'll see that when we actually go
through the phases in fact the prophase
metaphase anaphase telophase also exist
in each of these phases of meiosis so
let me just draw the end product so the
end product is you have four cells
four cells and each of them
are haploid
each of these are haploid and you could
already see you know this this process
right here you essentially split up your
your chromosomes because you end up with
half in each one but here you start with
n and you end up with two chromosomes
that each have n so it's very similar to
this you can preserve the number of
chromosomes so let's delve into the
details of how it all happens
so all cells spend most of their time in
interphase interphase is just a time
when the cell is you know living and and
and transcribing and doing what it needs
to do
but just like in mitosis one key thing
does happen in during the interphase and
actually it happens during the same
thing the s phase of the interphase so
if that's my cell
that's my
nucleus right here and i'm going to draw
it as chromosomes but you have to
remember that when we're outside of
mitosis for or meiosis formally the
chromosomes are all unwound and they
exist as
chromatin which we've talked about
before it's kind of the unwound state of
the dna but i'm going to draw them wound
up because i need to show you that they
replicate
now i'm going to be a little careful
here in the mitosis video i just had two
chromosomes they replicated and then
they split apart when we talk about
meiosis we have to be careful to show
the homologous pairs so let's say that i
have two homologous pairs so let's say i
have
so this is the one let me do it in
appropriate colors so this is the one i
got from my dad
this is the one i got from my mom
they're homologous
and let's say that i have another one
that i got from my dad
that is
oh let me say say it's let me do it in
blue
actually maybe i should do all the ones
from my dad in this color
maybe it's a little bit longer you get
the idea and then a homologous one for
my mom that's also a little bit longer
now during the s phase of the interphase
and this is just like what happens in
mitosis so this kind of you can almost
view it as it's always it always happens
during interphase it doesn't happen in
either meiosis or mitosis you have
replication of your dna
so each of these from the homologous
pair and remember homologous pairs mean
that they're not identical chromosomes
but they do code for the same genes they
might have different versions or
different alleles for a gene or for a
certain trait but they code essentially
for the same kind of stuff
now replication of these so each of
these chromosomes in this pair
replicate
so that one from my dad replicates
like this
it replicates and it's connected by a
centromere and the one from my mom
replicates
like that and it's connected
by a centromere right that and then the
other one does as well that's the
shorter one or that's the longer one
actually
that's the longer one i should be a
little bit more explicit in which ones
shorter and longer the one from my mom
does the same thing this is in the s
phase of interface we haven't entered
the actual cell division yet
and the same thing is true and this is
kind of a little bit of a sideshow of
the centrosomes and we saw in the
mitosis video that these are involved
and kind of eventually dr creating the
microtubule structure and pulling
everything apart but you'll have one
centrosome that's hanging out here and
then it facilitates its its own
replication so then you have two
centrosomes so this is all occurring in
the interphase
in the interphase and particularly in
the s part of the interface not the
growth part interphase but once that's
re once that happens we're ready in fact
we're ready for either mitosis or
meiosis but we're going to do meiosis
now this is a germ cell so what happens
is we enter into
prophase one so if you remember in my
let me write this down because i think
it's important in mitosis
you have
prophase
metaphase
anaphase
and telophase
i won't keep writing phase down or pmat
in meiosis you experience these in each
stage so you have
prophase 1 followed by metaphase 1
followed by anaphase 1 followed by
telophase 1. then after you've done
meiosis 1 then it all happens again you
have prophase 2 followed by metaphase 2
followed by anaphase 2 followed by
telophase so if you really just want to
memorize the names which you
unfortunately have to do in this
especially if you're going to get tested
on it
although it's not that important to kind
of understand the concept the concept of
what's happening you just have to
remember prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase it'll really cover everything
you just have to memorize in in meiosis
it's happening twice it's happening
twice and what's happening is a little
bit different and that's what i really
want to focus on here so let's enter
prophase one of myo of meiosis one so
this let me call this prophase
prophase
one
so what's going to happen so just like
in prophase and mitosis a couple of
things start happening your nuclear
envelope starts i shouldn't say your
nuclear envelope starts disappearing
your nuclear envelope star starts
disappearing so it starts
nuclear envelope stars the centromeres
sorry center i'm going to configure
these centrosomes the centromeres are
these things connecting these sister
chromatids but the centrosomes start
facilitating the the development of
these spindles and they start pushing
apart a little bit
from the spindles
they start pushing apart and going in
going to opposite sides of the
chromosomes and this is the really
important thing in prophase one well and
actually i'll make this point remember
an interface even though i drew it this
way these they don't exist in this state
the actual chromosomes they exist more
in a chromatin state so if i were to
really draw it it would look like
it would look like this the chromosomes
you know i'd have a it'd all be all over
the place and you actually would be very
difficult to actually see it in a
microscope it would just be a big mess
of of of proteins and of histones which
are proteins and the actual dna and so
and that's what's actually referred to
as the chromatin now in prophase that
starts to form into the chromosomes it
starts to have a little bit of structure
and this is completely analogous to what
happens in prophase in mitosis now the
one interesting thing happens is that
the homologous pairs line up and
actually i drew it like that over here
maybe i should just cotton cut and paste
it let me just do that
so if i just
cut and paste
if i just cut and paste that
although i said that the the nucleus is
is disappearing so let me get rid of the
nucleus i already said that the nucleus
is slowly disassembling
the proteins are coming apart during
this prophase one i won't draw the whole
cell here because what's interesting
here is happening at the nuclear or what
was once what once was the nucleus level
so the interesting thing here that's
different about than from mitosis is
that the homologous pairs line up next
to each other not only do they line up
but they can actually share they can
actually this is because they can
actually have genetic recombination so
you have these points where analogous or
i guess you could say homologous points
on the two on two of these chromosomes
will cross over each other so let me
draw that in detail so let me just focus
on maybe these two right here
so this is so i have one for my
one chromosome from my dad
and it's made up of two chromatids so
it's already replicated but we only
consider it one chromosome and then i
have one from my mom
and green
and i have one for my mom and i'm gonna
i'm gonna draw it like that
one for my mom in green and it also has
two chromatids and sometimes this is
called a tetrad
a tetrad because it has four chromatrids
in it
but it's in a pair of homologous
chromosomes these are the centromeres of
course what happens is you have crossing
over and it's actually a very it's a
surprisingly um uh
i guess organized process when i say
organize it it crosses over at a
homologous point it crosses over at a
point where for the most part you're not
you're exchanging similar genes you're
not you know it's not like you're
getting one is getting two versions of
the gene the other is getting two
versions in another gene you're
exchanging in a way that both
chromosomes are still encoding for the
different genes but they're getting
different versions of those genes or
different uh different alleles which are
just versions of those genes so once
this is done
you have the ones from my father are now
not completely from my father so it
might look something like this
let me see it look like this
it'll the one from my father now has
this little bit from my mother
and the one from my i know that my my
mother's chromosome is green
a little bit from my mother and the one
from my mother
has a little bit from my father
and this is really amazing because it
shows you that it was this is so
favorable for creating variation in a
population that it's it's really become
a formal part of the meiosis process it
happens so frequently this isn't just
some random fluke and it happens in a
reasonably organized way and that it
actually happens at a point where it
doesn't uh where it doesn't kind of
create junk uh junk genes because you
can imagine this could have this cutoff
point which is called a which is called
a chiasma it could have happened in the
middle of some gene and it could have
created some all this you know random
noise and it could have broken down some
protein development in the future who
knows what but it doesn't happen that
way it happens in a reasonably organized
way which kind of speaks to the idea
that it's part of the process so in
prophase one you also have this
happening so once that happens you could
have
this guy's got a little bit of
that
chromatid and then
this guy's got a little bit of that
chromatid
so all of this stuff happens in prophase
one you have this crossing over the the
the nuclear envelope starts to
disassemble and then all of these guys
align and the chromatin starts forming
into these more tightly wind structures
of chromosomes and really that's all you
know when we talk about even mitosis
that's where a lot of the action really
took place once that happens then we're
ready to enter into the metaphase one so
let's go down to metaphase one
so in metaphase one
let me just copy and
let me copy and paste what i've already
done
the nuclear envelope is now gone
the centrosomes
have gone to opposite sides of the
of the
cell itself maybe i should draw the cell
the entire cell now now that there's no
nucleus let me erase the nucleus a
little bit better than i've done
let me erase all of that
and of course we have the spindle fibers
that have been that have been generated
by now
with the help of the centrosomes
and some of them we learned this is
exactly what happened in in mitosis they
attached to the kinetochores which are
attached to the center the centromeres
the centromeres
of these chromosomes now what's
interesting here is that they each
attach so this guy is going to attach to
and actually let me let me let me make
do something interesting here instead of
doing it this way because i want to show
that all my dad's chromosomes don't go
to one side and all my mom's chromosomes
don't go to the other side so instead of
drawing these two guys like this let me
see if i can flip them
let me see let me just flip them the
other way
whether or not they're which direction
they're flipped is completely random and
that's what adds to the variation
as we said before sexual reproduction is
key to introducing variation into a
population so that's the moms and that's
the dad they don't have to all of the
ones from my dad might have ended up on
one side and all of them from my mom
might end up on one side although with
when you're talking about 23 pairs the
probability becomes a lot lot lower
so this is one for my dad
and of course it has some
centromeres let me draw that there
and so
these micro spindles some of them attach
to kinetochores which are these protein
structures on the centromeres
and this is just like metaphase it's
very similar to metaphase in mitosis
this is called metaphase
metaphase one and everything aligns now
we're going to enter anaphase one
now anaphase one is interesting
because remember when we when we in
mitosis in anaphase the actual
chromatids the sister chromatids
separated from each other that's not the
case in anaphase one here in meiosis
so
when we enter anaphase one
you have just a homologous pair separate
so the chromatids stay with their sister
chromatids
so on this side
you'll have these two go there and let
me just
well i have the green out let me
see if i can
see if i can draw this respectively
i have the purple
it's a little bit shorter
version here
he's got a little bit of a stub of green
there
this guy's got a little stub of purple
and then they have this longer purple
chromosome here this is anaphase one
they're being pulled apart but they're
being pulled apart
the homologous pair is being pulled
apart not the actual chromosomes not the
chromatids are being so let me just draw
this this
so then you have your microtubules some
are connected to these kinetochores you
have your centromeres
and of course all of this is occurring
within the sound these are getting
pulled apart
so it's analogous
to anaphase in mitosis but the key
difference is you're pulling apart
you're pulling apart homologous pairs
you're not actually splitting the
chromosomes into their constituent
chromatids
and that's key and if you you forget
that you can review the mitosis video so
this is anaphase one
anaphase one
and then as you can imagine telophase
one is essentially once these guys are
at their respective ends
of the cell
once they're at their respective ends
it's getting tiring redrawing all of
these but i guess it gives you time to
to let it all sink in
so these guys are now at the left end of
the cell
and now these guys
are now at the right end of the cell
now the microtubules start to
disassemble so you know maybe you know
they're they're there a little bit but
they're disassembling you still have
your centromeres here and they're
opposite poles and to some degree the
early part of telephase they're still
pushing the cell apart at the same time
you have cytokinesis happening
so by the end of telophase one so you
have this
this the actual cytoplasm is splitting
during telophase
right there and the nuclear envelope is
forming it's off it's almost you can
almost view it as the opposite of
prophase
the opposite of prophase the nuclear
envelope is forming and by the end of
telophase one it will have completely
divided so this is telophase one
now notice we started off
with the diploid cell
right it had it had two pairs of
homologous chromosomes but it had four
chromosomes
now
each cell only has two chromosomes it is
essentially each cell got one of uh one
of the pair of each of those homologous
pairs but it was done randomly and
that's where that's where a lot of the
variation is introduced now once we're
at this stage each of these cells now
undergo
meiosis ii which is actually very
similar to mitosis
and sometimes there's actually an
in-between stage called interphase 2
where the cell kind of rests and
whatever else and actually the the
centromeres now have to duplicate again
so what is the these two cells i've
drawn them separately let's let's see
what happens next so let's say that the
the centromere actually i shouldn't have
drawn the centromere inside the nucleus
like that the centromere is going to be
outside the nucleus
outside of the newly formed nucleus
there and there
and then it actually it'll they'll
actually it'll replicate itself at this
point as well
so now we have two cells
let me just
cut and paste what i have before well
now
i wanted to be let me so i have this one
this chromosome
right here it's got this little green
stub there and then i have this longer
fully green chromosome there now this
guy
he's got this
he's got he's he's let me make he's got
this little purple stub here let me draw
this whole
purple chromosome there
and then this
has one chromatid like that and one
chromatid like that
now when we enter prophase two
prophase two
what do you think is going to happen
well just like before
you have your nuclear envelope that
formed in telophase one it's you know
it's kind of a temporary thing it starts
to disintegrate again
it starts to disintegrate again
starts to disintegrate
and then you have your your centromeres
they go they start pushing apart so now
i had two centromeres they replicated
and now they start pushing apart while
they generate their little spindles they
push apart in opposite direction now
this is happening in two cells of course
they go in opposite directions while
they generate their spindle fibers and
let me make it very clear that this is
two cells we're talking about
that's one of them
and that's the second of them
now it's going to enter metaphase 2
metaphase
2 which is analogous to metaphase 1 or
metaphase and mitosis where the
chromosomes get lined up and let me draw
it this way so they get so now the
centromeres they've migrated to the two
poles of the cell
so this is my those are my centromeres i
have all of my spindle fibers
of my spindle fibers
oh sorry did i call those centromeres
the centrosomes centrosomes the cen
these have i've been i don't know how
long i've been calling them centromeres
these are centrosomes that my brain
keeps confusing the centromeres and
maybe this will help you not do what i
just did the centromeres are the things
that are connecting the two sister
chromatids those are centromeres
centrosomes are the things that are are
pushing back the that generate the
spindle fibers and i the chromosomes
line up during metaphase metaphases
always involves the lining up of
chromosomes so that one let me just draw
it so that and that
this one's got a purple guy too
this guy's got a purple guy a long
purple guy and then there's a little
stub for the other guy this guy's got a
long green guy
a long green guy and this guy's got a
little green stub
and then this guy's got this is the
short green guy right there and of
course they're being aligned some of
these spindle fibers have been attached
to the centromeres or the kinetochores
that are on the centromeres
that connect these two chromatids these
sister chromatids and of course we don't
have a nuclear membrane anymore and
these are of course two separate
cells and then you can guess what
happens in the in anaphase ii it's just
like anaphase in mitosis
anaphase
ii these things get pulled apart by
these by the kinetochore microtubules
while the other microtubules keep
growing and push and push these two
things further apart so let me show that
and this the key here this is the
difference between anaphase two and
anaphase one anaphase one
anaphase one the homologous pairs were
broken up but the chromosomes themselves
were not
now in anaphase two we don't have
homologous pairs we just have chromatid
pairs sister chromatids now those are
separated and it's just which is very
similar to anaphase in mitosis
so now you know this guy gets pulled in
that direction so it looks something
like this
the drawing here is the hardest part of
this video
so that guy gets pulled there that guy's
getting pulled in that direction
he's got that little green stub on him
and then you have one green guy getting
pulled in that direction this is the
longer chromosome
and then one of the other longer is
getting pulled in that direction and
it's all by these microtubules connected
at the kinetochore structures
by a centrosome is kind of the
coordinating
body
it's all being pulled apart anaphase has
always involved the pulling part of the
chromosomes well or pulling a part of
something let me put it that way and
it's happening on this side of the
cell as well of course this is all
one cell and just like just like in
mitosis as soon as the sister chromatids
are split apart they are now referred to
as chromosomes or sister chromosomes and
of course this is happening twice this
is also happening in the other cell
this is also happening in the other cell
the other cell's a little bit cleaner
because it didn't have that crossover
occur
so you have
you have the longer
purple one
he gets split up into two chromatids
which we we are now calling chromosomes
or sister chromosomes and then this guy
up here
he gets split up into the short green
and then
there's a let me do it this way
this short green and he's got a little
purple stub on it right there and of
course it's all being pulled away by the
same idea by the
centrosomes i want to make sure i get
that word right
i'm afraid whether i use centromeres for
the whole first part of the video but
hopefully my confusion will help you
from getting confused because you'll
you'll realize that it's a pitfall to
fall into so that's anaphase everything
is getting pulled apart and then you can
imagine what telophase 2 is telophase 2
in fact i won't even redraw it telophase
2 these things get pulled apart even
more so this is telophase
telophase
2 they get pulled apart even more the
cell elongates you start having this
this this
cleavage occur
right here
so at the same time the telophase two
these get pulled apart and you have the
cytokinesis
the tubules start disintegrating and
then you have
a nucleus that forms around these
so what is the end result of all of
these
well that guy is going to turn into let
me draw
he's going to turn into a nucleus that
has
this purple dude with a little green
stub
and then a long green guy
and then he's got his nuclear membrane
and of course there's the entire
cytoplasm in the rest of the cell
the other person is that was his kind of
partner in this meiosis ii
is going to have a
short purple
a short purple and a long green
and along green he has a nuclear
membrane
the nuclear membrane and of course it
has cytoplasm around it
and then on this side you have something
similar to happening see this first guy
this first one right here is a two long
purple ones
get separated so let me see you have one
long purple in that cell and then you
have another long purple in this cell
and then in that top one you have a
short green one and this bottom when you
have a short green one that had got a
little bit of a one of my dad's
a homologous part of one of my dad's
chromosomes on it and of course these
also have nuclear membranes
nuclear membranes and
of course has a cytoplasm in the rest of
the cell which will learn more about all
of their other things so what we see
here is that we went from a diploid
starting way where did we start we
started up here with a diploid
germ cell and we went through two stages
of division the first stage split up
homologous pairs but it started over
with that crossing over that genetic
recombination which is a key feature of
meiosis which adds a lot of variation
to a species or to a gene pool
and then the second phase separated the
sister chromatids just like what happens
in mitosis and we end up with four
haploid cells because they have half the
contingency of chromosomes and these are
called gametes
gametes